well it is over but it's not done early
this morning State lawmakers adjourned
the legislative session but they didn't
finish their work so that means a
special session and it also means a
stadium project is in Jeopardy while a
film studio tax incentive package is
likely dead here's our John langler he's
up in Carson City as all this drama has
been playing out
good morning it all happened right here
in the Senate chambers the conclusion of
the hectic final days of the legislative
session became clear when the minority
leader here in the Senate well she
rejected the last big budget Bill the
room was packed at the time lobbyists
journalists Spectators they gathered to
see if the Senate could do what the
assembly had pretty much done finish
their business through the day there
were signs of compromise some signs also
of distance between the democratic-led
legislature and the Republicans both
here in the legislature and next door in
the governor's office by the end it was
the Capital Improvements planning
measure the last big budget item
millions of dollars billions even
Senator Heidi Sievers Ganser said
Republicans could not support it making
a special session inevitable so here we
are again
11 26 at night
our requests are simple we've made it
clear we're looking for Equity we want
to make sure charter schools get funding
we want to continue to expand the
healthcare pipeline so for these reasons
we'll be opposed to ab521 thank you
Republican and Democratic sources say
the session will likely happen this week
and again the key item is the budget so
that brings up the other two main issues
we've talked about legislation to
approve the A's stadium that financing
bill that could also come up in this
special session however the four billion
dollar Film Studio tax incentive measure
that is likely dead
in Carson City John langler 8 News Now